the Rockefeller Center Christmas tree
here in New York is one of the most
iconic symbols in Christmas and one of
its biggest but after the lights come
down the giant Norway spruce has a less
public second life
brook silva-braga is here with the story
what good morning good morning guys the
tree of course is huge usually between
70 and 90 feet tall capped with millions
of crystals covered in thousands of
lights but beneath all that sparkle is a
good amount of wood and after it's taken
down each January it is put to a good
use that lasts long beyond the holidays
each fall a tree is chopped out of
obscurity and escorted with great
fanfare to the heart of New York City
[Music]
for a month or so covered in five miles
of lights co-starring and all those
selfies it is Christmas big right
commercial temporary for the last 12
years when that season of attention has
passed Tishman Speyer the real estate
company running Rockefeller Center has
milled the tree down for boards and
brought it to a building site you see
that tree is this monster tree and all
the wood that gets autumn it comes in a
pickup truck volunteers from Habitat for
Humanity use those boards to help make a
home its pine so it's not the strongest
wood but it's wood that we appreciate
I've got green trend I can say you know
see that tree that last year it's in
this house last year's tree made it here
to Newburgh New York last summer to be
drilled into the rafters of an abandoned
fixer-upper that would one day belong to
Letitia Atkins did you ever go as a kid
to the see the tree yes my grandmother
took me to see the tree I remember us
going through the crowd of people walk
in to see the Christmas tree get lit
your grandmother's important
yeah she's she raised me from the
hospital when nobody didn't want me she
took me
the sturdy home has long been hard for a
Lakeisha to find her grandmother's place
was crowded with distant cousins
she says they didn't like her and some
of them abused her I didn't understand
why I wasn't getting treated so bad I
didn't understand why they hated me so
much yeah I can't imagine anyone would
understand that can you imagine and
six-way praying for a kid just to have
somebody to love you but then realizing
that you just have to follow up with
inside yourself eventually Lakeisha also
found love with Larry Atkins an aspiring
plumber she met at a party they married
and started raising five kids together
our plan was I go to school and get my
degree he supported me then he go to
school and get his plumbing we get a
good job and then we get a house but
before that could happen in 2015
Lakeisha got a terrible phone call and
she was like Larry got shot Larry got
shot in his head and was dead before he
hit the ground
but Habitat for Humanity families do not
get their homes in exchange for a sad
story volunteer labor makes the house
affordable but Lakeisha will be on the
hook for the mortgage qualify she had to
take budgeting classes and put in
hundreds of hours of her own work and
this place looks terrible but it also
looks amazing like just the space the
potential just like me growing up I was
an empty show nobody saw me for who I
have potential to be they saw me at that
moment for what I was so I see my house
for what it's going to be not for what
it is right now
it was June when we first visited that
empty shell of a building by last week
it had been transformed and Lakeisha
officially got the keys to her family's
future
[Applause]
[Music]
God doesn't give you what you pray for
God gives you what you need when you
need it so he answered your prayers I
had one time I just would tell that girl
that's Lena I bet crying cuz she hungry
cuz you've been traumatized because
she'd been abused
just keep God trust God that's the only
thing that got me where I'm at already
Lakeisha says she wants to stay involved
with habitat by helping other families
get through the program it can be a
difficult lengthy process but her pitch
to other families is if a single mother
of five can do it you can too wow what
an inspirational story and woman she is
just I mean that talking about the house
being an empty shell and the potential
and that she needed somebody she was the
one that had to see that in herself I
unbelievable
I love the love story of those two
people and it's so sad cuz she had to
lose them and yet she has such
resilience for her children yeah it's
obviously been really really hard on
that family but we get to spend a bunch
of time with them both this summer and
this week and her and those kids are
doing well and they are so excited to
finally move into this house the
household thanks to that tree yeah think
about that yeah back to them a look at
that tree different yeah I'll see a
different story a lovely story thank you